welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and it's hard out here for a batch
didn't think i could do 11 weeks of
terrible puns like that but here we are
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down the latest entry of the
bad batch
episode 11 is filled with easter eggs
hidden details
and callbacks to the greatest star wars
story full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then i highly recommend that you check
out now
like the video subscribe and at me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
to never miss an update from the channel
without the way
yoda man or woman now let's get into the
bad batch
okay so last episode we watched as the
bad batch were tasked with rescuing a
separatist senator
this made the bad batch really question
what they were doing as the clone wars
were of course very black and white
on the surface it was clearly good
versus bad but behind the scenes we know
that palpatine was controlling both
sides in the war
in order to prop himself up as the
leader of the galactic empire
this idea of there being shades of grey
lace throughout the galaxy
is also slowly becoming laced into every
aspect of the show
now we have seen that omega has been
hunted by bounty hunters
with them constantly going after her
like there was a sale at the dorth mall
and everything was half off this meant
that hunter decided to leave her behind
on the previous mission
but after she became a hollow chest
wizard and paid off their debt to sid
he realized he'd underestimated her this
idea of underestimation is of course
very common throughout star wars
and i think that going forward we will
very much see her come into our own by
the end of the season
now episode 11 is called devil's deal a
play on the phrase a deal with the devil
which means to agree to something with
someone you can't trust
who will probably screw you over in some
way also mephisto confirmed
now this episode has the seeds of the
rebellion being sewn and we pick up on
ryloth the home of the twilights
also i can't remember if it's tweedlex
or twilight's so
my bad if i got it wrong now it's
currently being occupied by the empire
enemy watch's crosshair scans the crowd
looking for threats
this is where we catch up with the
character goby glee who was part of the
resistance during the clone wars
ryloth was occupied by the separatist
alliance and he helped to fight back in
order to earn his people's freedom
glee would go on to help the free ryloth
movement get their planet back
and he's very much an opposite to
senator who we too come across in this
intro
now you might recognize tar from the
prequel trilogy and this self-indulgent
and corrupt character
used the political system on his planet
to further his own ends
tor says that he's happy the empire has
taken over and we also see cham syndola
and his wife elena who are of course big
characters in the star wars universe
you may know that from canon cham's wife
would go on to be killed
and that this would push hera down a
certain path in fighting the imps
whilst her father went down another as
for hera she's been a big name in the
expanded universe
and her last appearance before this
property was in star wars squadron
which you should definitely pick up now
that game is set after the events of
this show
but i love that she's slowly starting to
pop up in more and more things the name
hera is a nod to greek mythology
namely the wife of zeus and she was very
much the queen of heaven
now as for cham he would go on to help
the rebellion against the empire
and here we very much see how he's the
real leader of his people
rather than tar because of the good that
the clones did for ryloth during the war
it's easy to convince the tweelex that
joining the empire is the right thing to
do
and this opening is very much in
opposite to last week's which was about
opposing them as much as possible now
shout outs ryan airy from screencrush
for pointing out that the prequel and
original trilogy
are very much like world war one and
world war ii respectfully
the first war was very much black and
white and quite easy to get your head
around
soldiers fought on the front line and
the messaging was very very simple
everyone was following orders fighting
soldiers and the hate that they had for
one another wasn't based on subjects
like race and religion
however people did start to hate the
other side and metaphorically in star
wars this can be shown through the
droids
in the prequel trilogy they were of
course the enemy and by a new hope even
the good ones weren't allowed to go into
bars
now just before the second world war
those in power realized that they could
motivate and manipulate people
through using propaganda making the
german population
hate jewish people motivated the mass
murder of millions
and i think that star wars is certainly
showing us how hate can be weaponized
into almost brainwashing a population to
carry out evil acts
if you can get your people to hate a
certain group then they will have no
problem in having their rights taken
away
and this is something that we still see
today with subjects like immigration and
refugees
getting very deep on the channel now but
i like that this show is very much
hinting at the broader picture of how
society works
and it's making us realize why the
empire was able to come in and take
control
they had the messaging and the might and
thus could make people power before them
now we cut to hera spying on some
imperials with a droid
chopper its periscope pops out first
similar to how artyditus did
during return of the jedi hera has been
sent on a reconnaissance mission by her
father's lieutenant goby
and we see very much how she admires the
life and be of the planet this would of
course
all be taken away by the empire and the
moment is short-lived when two clone
troopers arrive
their shadow casts over her picturesque
view and this darkness spreading over
the land has of course been used as a
framing device in several star wars
properties
to show how they completely engulf
everything they touch now though gobi is
referred to as her
uncle i don't actually think that he is
and instead he's just a close friend of
cham
the empire taking over things is very
much felt amongst the people
who don't want clones defending their
ranks however cham very much views war
as being something that they shouldn't
be subjected to anymore
and thus he's happy to let others take
over even though we know exactly where
this leads
clown trooper houses says things are
already tense and this is clearly the
case
as gobi is of course creating spies
amongst the people
and listing them for war once more he's
very much in opposite to cham
and gobi knows the imperials are up to
something hausa also may be named after
josie hauser
who has created numerous star wars
comics cut to rampart meaning tar
and we see the pair making a deal that
will ensure cham and gobi are taken out
before they can cause too much trouble
we also see crosshair for the first time
without bandages and can make out that
the guys got a nifty score now
scars are of course signs of villains
and fiction and before you start yet
i've got i've got loads of them and i'm
a nice guy
however i think that it might actually
start to indicate exactly the path that
he's going on
and it is possible that crosshair will
be freed from his chip
but that he'll still choose to remain
with the empire because that's kind of
where he's made his bed
hera sees that the birds in the sky have
been replaced by ships
showcasing how nature has been changed
hera is clearly fixated on flying
and this idea of longing whilst looking
at a ship is something that ray did in
the force awakens
she just wants to leave this place and
as we know
she would go on to become an expert
pilot hera helped to build a resistance
movement on board the ghost
and she teamed up with kane and jairus
aka caleb dume
who he watched escape order 66 all the
way back in episode 1.
unfortunately we learned that the deal
with the imperials was very much a
devil's deal
eh and they've turned the agreed
refinery into a military facility
now shout out simon a birman on twitter
for pointing out that they're digging
for dunium
which would be a material that would be
used in the construction of the death
star
chambrays they don't alter the deal any
further and this clearly troubles his
wife who sees that they're giving up
their freedom for safety
however this always comes with
oppression and it doesn't sit well
amongst the others
hera and gobi end up flying out together
and we see that they're tracked by
crosshair
hera gets to fly the ship and from this
you can gather why she's so fond of goby
as he's very much a flight instructor
turns out they're meeting the bachelor
brought weapons for them
and there was even a point in this
episode that i didn't think they'd show
up at all
however they've brought things to arm
the resistance and it very much shows
how they were instrumental to the
creation of the rebellion in more ways
than one
hera is fascinated by their ship and
omega gives her the grand tour
it gives the pair some time to bond and
i really hope that just
in star wars canon that omega shows up
at some point further down the line
perhaps in the book of boba or the
mandalorian i'd love to see her in the
former as he is of course her brother
but it's nice to see her interacting
with these other star wars characters
the pair have a really good exchange and
we see what life is like for kids caught
up in this war
for them it's normal and they don't even
realize they're in trouble
because they're so used to it goby and
co return home but crossair takes out
their engines which
allows a clone transport to come in and
capture them they have little option and
thus have to hand themselves in
and they're surrounded by speeder bikes
which carry the same sound effects as
the ones from the return of the jedi
rampart arrives in a turbo tank and
doesn't bow to the power play that tar
wants
but clearly the clones are starting to
question this move as
hauser says she's just a child i love
how descent is slowly starting to sink
amongst the ranks
and chopper informs hera's father and
mother that they've been found guilty of
treason
even without a trial thus they launch a
rescue mission
and it clearly becomes a devil's deal as
the imperials are almost
sort of happy to watch this entire thing
play out rampart and houses seem to be
letting toss the other ship
as they know either way they have the
power to control whatever the outcome is
rampart makes them surrender but it's
purely so that they can see if cham
ceases control of the situation
and executes star however he refuses to
murder him in cold blood
unfortunately the imperials still need
him out the way and crosshair shoots
tall before they're arrested for the
attempted assassination
i'm guessing that because he pops up and
cannon down the line and this is a kid's
show that they don't just murder him
and hey that also makes sense as to why
everyone seems to be using stun blasts
her chair and his wife are captured and
potentially we will see the events that
lead to her death in the next entry
era goes on the run and going forward i
think she'll of course reach out to the
batch
but also will have some help from hauser
he did seem to be questioning orders and
that's normally a good sign amongst the
clone troopers
so hey i don't think they would have put
that in place if it's not gonna pay off
down the line
they might even bring kayla back into it
to bring everything full circle
and i am excited to see what happens
next time as potentially we could see
the formation of rebels
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the show in the comments below
and as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of july
in which we're giving away three mcu box
sets all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 5 of loki which will be linked
on screen right now
we pointed out all the easter eggs in a
very easter egg filled episode
and it's definitely worth checking out
if you want something else to watch
without the way thank you for singing
through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace